[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a un nuevo
episodio de boleto de vuelta que en esta
ocasión nos lleva a sir lanka país que
vivió durante 25 años una cruenta guerra
civil las raíces del conflicto se
remontan a la colonización británica
cuando la isla de ceilán como se
denominaba sir lanka en ese entonces
obtuvo su independencia en 1948 la
mayoría cingalesa budista tomó el poder
las minorías tamil hindú y cristiana
fueron acusadas de haber sido cercanas a
los colonos y por ende marginadas en
1972 en el noreste del país los
separatistas tamiles se organizaron y
apareció un movimiento armado los tigres
tamiles que exigían la creación de un
estado independiente
también elam las tensiones técnicas
aumentaron en 1977 los disturbios contra
los tamiles estallaron en todo el país
causando cientos de muertes entre la
minoría la guerrilla de los tigres
realiza operaciones contra el ejército
decir blanca y en represalia en todo el
país se organizan ataques contra los
tamiles es el comienzo de la guerra
civil que durará hasta 2009 cuando se
elimina la guerrilla de los tigres se
estima que el conflicto dejó al menos
100.000 muertos y les pasados y
desaparecidos la mayoría de las víctimas
civiles son tamiles 13 años después de
la reconciliación sigue siendo difícil
miles de personas siguen buscando a sus
seres queridos y la verdad
estamos en el corazón de bani en el
norte de sri lanka la región fue uno de
los bastiones de los tigres de
liberación de tamil eelam tlte
esta tierra quedó marcada por 25 años de
guerra civil hasta 2009 una herida que
ahora es invisible es salvo por los
omnipresentes controles militares
aquí los civiles de la minoría también
son los grandes perdedores de la guerra
víctimas colaterales de los combates
entre el ejército de sri lanka y los
tigres muchos murieron o desaparecieron
en la actualidad de unos 100 mil hogares
de la región están a cargo de mujeres
cabeza de familia
valgan
me lanzo sin pensar demasiado en lo que
podría salir mal incluso tomaré un
autobús para llegar allí
estaba hablando con cear hojas sobre
esto si te pones a pensar en las
consecuencias no haces nada
dime a qué hora debe venir mañana puedes
venir a las 7 no en realidad ven a las 6
a tu casa si aquí de acuerdo ahí estaré
ven a las 6 am creo que como miles de
mujeres jenny no ha vuelto a ver a su
esposo el padre de sus dos hijos desde
el 19 de agosto de 2007 el día en que
fue detenido por los soldados cuando
volvía a casa del trabajo para comer era
conductor de autobús
[Música]
tendrás que subirte a ese autobús invita
todas tus vecinas no dejes a nadie atrás
hoy el teléfono celular de yenín no para
de timbrar está coordinando una
manifestación de mujeres tamiles que
buscan a un ser querido desaparecido
durante la guerra el objetivo es
recorrer 80 kilómetros en autobús sin
ser interceptadas y reunirse en un lugar
simbólico el día de la independencia de
sri lanka
por su seguridad y la de sus familiares
estas mujeres nos pidieron que nos
rebelaremos sus nombres reales al
organizar una manifestación se exponen a
las represalias y presiones de las
autoridades que aún son sistemáticas 13
años después del final de la guerra
en nuestra mente nunca somos libres
siempre estamos desesperadas lloramos
cuando comemos lloramos cuando dormimos
e incluso cuando salimos para una boda
por ejemplo no podemos ser felices
porque en el fondo nuestro corazón llora
por nuestros hijos perdidos mañana
celebrarán el día de la independencia
pero para nosotras es un día de dolor y
nos vestiremos de negro tras la
independencia de re lanka en 1948 las
relaciones entre la mayoría cingalesa
gobernante y la minoría tamil se
deterioraron constantemente hasta la
guerra civil al legado de la nación
adora discotecas
es mi único hijo iba a la escuela en
bicicleta con su morral en la espalda
nunca regresó realmente no sabemos qué
hacer todos los años en la época de las
fiestas rezo para que mi hijo vuelva a
celebrarlo con nosotros
pero ese deseo nunca se hizo realidad
nos tortura
no lo es
mira que estos son algunos de nuestros
familiares desaparecidos y secuestrados
hay muchos otros los rostros que
aparecen en estas fotos pertenecen a las
personas detenidas por los soldados
ninguno de ellos regresó con nosotros no
tenemos ni idea de dónde están pero
seguimos luchando con su foto en la mano
para sentirlo cerca de nosotros
sólo queremos que nos devuelvan a
nuestros seres queridos
nada más
personalmente creo que mi marido sigue
vivo eso es lo que me hace seguir
adelante
una condena que ha costado mucho a jenny
ya muchas otras mujeres volver a ver a
sus seres queridos las ong de derechos
humanos han recibido numerosos
testimonios que describen casos de acoso
sexual chantaje y extorsión a menudo por
parte de miembros de los servicios
militares y de investigación que
prometen a estas mujeres encontrar a sus
seres queridos a cambio de dinero o
servicios pero las denuncias de las
víctimas y las investigaciones
policiales nunca tienen éxito
en el extremo norte del país la
península de jaffna es el antiguo
bastión de los rebeldes tamiles en 1995
los tigres perdieron el control de la
ciudad de jaffna tras una batalla de 50
días que dejó cientos de muertos esta es
la casa de una de las principales
figuras en la lucha por la justicia para
las mujeres tamiles
annan tiza citarán es la esposa de uno
de los cuadros políticos de los tigres
apodado steel and que desapareció al
final de la guerra
esta es nuestra santo de boda tomada en
junio de 1988
[Música]
y esta es de 1999 cuando nación es el
primera hija
actualmente elegida en la provincia
norte del país anant y es la voz de las
mujeres en busca de los desaparecidos en
la política y en los tribunales al final
de la guerra animó a su marido a
rendirse con la esperanza de volver a
verlo con vida pero trece años después
andante y sus tres hijas siguen sin
tener noticias de él el último día de la
guerra el 18 de mayo de 2009 el gobierno
pidió a todos los que tuvieran alguna
relación con los rebeldes que se
entregaran al ejército esto fue lo
pensaron también marido y nuestros tres
hijos se nos prometió por los altavoces
que todos los que se rindieran serían
debidamente liberados
ahora anti quiere averiguar qué le
ocurrió a su marido y obligar al
gobierno a publicar la lista de tamiles
desaparecidos
y la
política para poder salvar a los que
sirvieron
ana garcía la banda de la noria nunca
mil cuando la gente empezó a apoyarme me
convirtió en una especie de portavoz del
sufrimiento de los familiares de los
desaparecidos
incluso después de todo este tiempo
todos estamos convencidos de que
nuestros seres queridos están escondidos
en algún lugar
tambor o que algún día les volveremos a
oír
anti se niega a ser considerada viuda
sin una prueba de la muerte de su marido
al que cree prisionero en un campo
secreto
y aquí están algunas cartas que envía
diferentes autoridades pidiendo la
generación de los que se entregaron y
este es un recorte de periódico del 10
de noviembre de 2011
en el que amnistía internacional
menciona siete campos de detención
secretos de norma
para la banda el gobierno de sri lanka
ha negado la existencia de estos campos
desde el final de la guerra pero en anti
no lo cree recientemente un tribunal
autorizó la reanudación de las
excavaciones en una de las mayores fosas
comunes descubiertas desde el final del
conflicto más de 300 esqueletos de
hombres mujeres y niños algunos de ellos
visiblemente atados una investigación
que podría aportar nuevas respuestas
d el gobierno guarda silencio y hace
oídos sordos a nuestras demandas porque
los desaparecidos xunta miles
y los que están en el poder no quieren
admitir sus crímenes
hoy no respetamos a nuestro presidente
en funciones porque es un hombre cruel
que cometió muchos abusos durante la
guerra
el gobierno tiene que admitir sus
errores no hay lugar para el compromiso
la búsqueda de justicia garantía ha sido
hasta ahora en vano mañana celebrará en
el día de la independencia
[Música]
en colombo la principal ciudad del país
el ejército de sri lanka desfila ante
sus líderes
[Música]
en la primera fila de dignatarios
presentes el presidente gotabaya
rajapaksa aquí con camisa blanca la
familia raya pacsa ya estaba en el poder
al final de la guerra aquí en posición
de firmes junto al presidente el general
shavendra silva actual jefe del ejército
fue comandante de división en 2009
durante la fase más sangrienta de la
guerra la de las acusaciones que recaen
sobre el proviene de las naciones
unidas- habría ordenado el bombardeo de
civiles en una zona de alto al fuego sus
crímenes de guerra le costaron la
prohibición de entrar a los eeuu
al amanecer de ese día 300 kilómetros al
norte de colombo jenny y sus compañeros
de luchas se preparan para partir el día
de la independencia es un día negro para
muchos civiles tamiles del país es un
recordatorio de su marginación por parte
de la mayoría cingalesa gobernante para
jenny esposa de uno de los desaparecidos
ha llegado el momento de pedir cuentas a
este poder una vez que la autobús está
protegido del mal de ojo es hora de
partir lo siento por las personas que
lleguen tarde
bien vamos los otros se las arreglan
vamos ya nos retrasamos
jenny tiene que recoger a unos 60
manifestantes sin llamar la atención
para no ser detenida por las autoridades
y poner en peligro a la manifestación
conoce los riesgos ha sido detenida
varias veces y se le ha prohibido
manifestarse hoy espera que su autobús
pase todos los obstáculos
es un cultura de tener el autobús
hay un futuro
bien eso no
sube date prisa
y la sal
después de unas diez paradas el autobús
está finalmente lleno sobre todo de
mujeres
es posible que tengamos algunos
problemas en el camino
[Música]
vamos directamente al lugar de la
manifestación y no sabemos si nos van a
parar o no van
casi hemos llegado a mullivaaykaal
ciento
mullivaikal es un lugar de memoria para
los tamiles de sri lanka una franja de
tierra junto al mar donde tuvieron lugar
los últimos enfrentamientos de la guerra
originalmente una zona de alto al fuego
cientos de miles de civiles quedaron
atrapados entre los tigres y las fuerzas
de la ncaa
en pocos días entre cuarenta y setenta
mil civiles tamiles fueron asesinados
según las naciones unidas
la mayoría de ellos murieron en
bombardeos ordenados por el ejército de
sri lanka tras más de dos horas de
camino jenny el convoy de manifestantes
llegaron sanos y salvos pero fueron
vigilados por numerosos policías
encubiertos que patrullaban
discretamente la zona
una presencia permanente lejos de
disuadir al grupo escoltada por varios
medios tamiles
hoy la organización de familiares de
desaparecidos ha reunido a miembros de 8
localidades para manifestarse en las
arenas de mullivaaykaal donde nuestra
gente murió en un baño de sangre y donde
muchos están enterrados y estamos
decididos a luchar sin descanso hasta
encontrar a los desaparecidos
hemos perdido nuestros derechos y
nuestros seres queridos pero nuestro
espíritu está vivo
tenemos que luchar con la fuerza que
llevamos dentro para que los tamiles
puedan vivir en estas tierras con los
derechos que merecen
llamado
a la grada
m
[Música]
el negro que llevamos hoy es un símbolo
de resistencia
hay cientos de ellas que se arriesgan a
manifestarse cada foto es una persona
desaparecida
estamos reunidos aquí con el dolor y la
tristeza para liberar nuestro peso
llevamos mucho tiempo luchando por la
justicia y la intervención internacional
pero nadie ha hecho justicia
aquí solo un pequeño monumento
vandalizado recuerda la masacre de
mullivaaykaal uno de los pocos lugares
de culto para los tamiles en el país
parte 1
[Música]
enamorando
en el día de la independencia el
gobierno afirma que sir lanka es un país
libre para toda la población nos
manifestamos aquí para mostrar la verdad
y la condición de los tamiles en este
oscuro día mientras nuestros seres
queridos desaparecidos no regresen
seguiremos luchando
las autoridades de sri lanka se han
negado sistemáticamente a someterse a
una investigación internacional sobre
los crímenes de guerra cometidos al
final del conflicto para jenny y todos
los que luchan por la verdad es
imposible aceptar los certificados de
defunción y las indemnizaciones del
gobierno hasta que las autoridades
aporten pruebas sobre el destino de sus
seres queridos para las familias de los
desaparecidos tamiles el duelo y la
reconciliación son actualmente
imposibles
[Música]
llegamos al final de este episodio de
boleto de vuelta a sir lanka recuerde
que si quiere ver este y otros episodios
en español puede visitar nuestra página
web france24 puntocom hasta pronto